growing businesses mean growing
complexity which leads to difficulties
in tracking and managing business
processes today I'll show you how to use
IBM BPM on cloud to transform your
business processes and efficiently
automate workflows with an easy-to-use
platform on cloud after I log in I can
access everything I need to develop test
and run processes I'll start in the
process Center where applications are
governed and deployed here I can access
the pre-built process starter kits
called accelerators these help me build
modify and deploy processes quickly I'll
use the claims process accelerator on
this specific case as a process
developer I can view the process map in
BPMN format including the screen flows
with swimlanes on the left this format
is easy to read for all parties working
on the process and I can modify the
process with drag-and-drop functionality
I can also modify the end-user screens
using the drag-and-drop capability of
BPM coaches it's easy to review the
screen flows I'm creating from beginning
to end in the process portal
since bpm on cloud contains functions to
develop deploy and run your processes
I'll show you an end user view of a
running process from the process portal
I can see my tasks and which ones are
late supervisors can also get easy to
consume data on how processes are
running BPM on cloud has an
administrative function to allow
self-service capabilities where
administrators can access log files
manage users set up data sources and
import certificates giving users a more
independent infrastructure IBM BPM on
cloud can help your company regardless
of size or experience create faster time
to value with an easy to deploy platform
to learn more about IBM BPM on cloud and
to sign up for the free trial visit the
IBM cloud marketplace
Oh